>>Josh: Good evening everybody. Thank you
for coming to Google. This is the third in
our series of artist's lectures at DigitalArts@Google.
I recognize some of you of having had been
here before. Thank you for coming back. I'll
take that as an endorsement. DigitalArts@Google
is a new program trying to investigate how
we can use the tool, the tools of art and
aesthetics to enhance people's understanding
of information. The art we selected for our
first exhibit was all balanced around the
sort of interface between data visualization
and databased art and the artists we have
this evening to, to speak to you epitomize
that balance; that there is data visualization
on one side and there is art art derived from
data on the other side and in-between there
is a magic space where you can create representations
of information that are both beautiful and
surprisingly informative in unexpected ways.
And with that introduction, I'd like to introduce
Martin Wattenberg and Fernanda Viegas, who
are--
>>other person: Viegas, is that the way you
pronounce it?
>>Fernanda: Yes, yes.
>>Josh: who have for many years been, been
among the forefront of scientists in data
visualization and who are artists in this
area as well and who I have been delighted
to discover a couple of weeks ago, have joined
me as colleagues at Google.
[Fernanda laughs]
Which means I get to work with them. And they're
here to talk to you about their work and their
ideas and I won't say anything more.
>>Fernanda: Great.
>>Martin: Great.
>>Fernanda: Thanks, Josh. So, we thought we'd
give you a sense of a lot of different projects.
We're gonna end up today, tonight talking
about the project that we have on the side,
Winterflow. But we thought we would regale
you with some of our other visualization projects.
And to start with we're gonna ta-, we're gonna
show something that you're all probably very
familiar with and here, lemme just. Oh. There,
ok. So, it's a project based on Google Suggest;
it's called the Web seer. And lemme see if
I can find out where we put it. Yes. So, if
you go to Google these days and you start
typing something. So let's say: "art". You
can see what Google is doing is it's suggesting
to you a bunch of possible continuations to
the term you have just typed, right? And so
this is called Google Suggest. And basically,
these are some of the most popular queries
that people have entered into Google based
on the, on the sent-, or on the word or phrase
that you just typed yourself. But it gets
more interesting when you realize that people
are not just looking for key words. They are
actually asking questions, right? So, you
get a sense of some of the most important
questions in people's lives these days. So,
what we decided to do is to actually go ahead
and visualize some of this information. So,
let me see--
>>Martin: It's a pretty important question.
>>Fernanda: Here. Ok.
>>Josh: [ ].
>>Fernanda: So, let's say I type "Why doesn't
he," right? And basically, what I'm doing
there is I'm visualizing exactly the same
information that Google was showing me before,
except that now, dealing with size and thicknesses
of arrows. So, the bigger the font the more
people are asking, the more popular that query
is. But then the other fun thing I can do
is compare that query against another one.
So, I'm gonna say, "Why doesn't he" versus
"why doesn't she."
[audience sigh]
And I can see what they share in common and
I can also get a sense of how the two genders
are different, right? "Why doesn't he call
me? Why doesn't he kiss me?" versus "Why doesn't
she leave?" Or--
>>Martin: Just--
[laughter]
>>Fernanda: Be quiet. "Why doesn't she just
leave?" Right?
>>Martin: Do I need the microphone or if I
talk like this am I?
>>Fernanda: I think they're being--
>>Martin: We're being recorded. All right.
I'll just do something like, ok. So, let's
look at the post dating phase and let's see.
Let's think about husbands and wives, say,
and "Why." What other phrase should we do?
"Why is--
>>Fernanda: Or, "is my."
>>Martin: Yeah. Let's do that, let's, let's
look at what people are asking about sort
of, "Is my husband" versus "Is my wife"--
[laughter]
and you sort of see the kind of interesting--
I dunno, end of the honeymoon, I guess you
might put it. It's, it's actually, the longer
you look at it, the less funny it becomes.
[laughter]
But it also becomes a pretty interesting window
into what's going on in the world.
>>Fernanda: So, continuing on with the family
life theme, how about turning to kids? "Is
my son" versus "Is my daughter."
[laughter]
And you can get a sense of the difference,
different anxieties that parents have depending
on the gender of their kids.
>>Martin: I will say that we have shown this
at various, different places in the country.
I don't know what Google is doing with this
cause I have no inside information on that,
but I will say that in different areas of
the country you get different results for
this. Here, it seems like New Yorkers are
worried about their daughters being overweight
and whether their sons are gifted. We did
a demo in the South where, "Is my son homosexual?"
was by far the largest worry.
>>Fernanda: And "Is my daughter pregnant?"--
>>Martin: Yeah.
>>Fernanda: was the other--
>>Martin: I think there's--
[laughter]
there's definitely, I think there's something
going on. You can also ask sort of more meta
questions. Let's take a look at, "How to be"
and we can see the things that people want
to be may be what you'd expect, "ninjaemo,"
I dunno. But then, just to get a little bit
philosophical, let's look at "How to pretend
to be" and interestingly the intersection
there is happiness.
[chuckling]
>>Josh: Pretend to be pregnant.
>>Martin: Makes you wonder.
>>Fernanda: Right, yeah. Absolutely. So, because
no demo is complete without politics, we can
now ask, "Are democrats" versus "Are republicans."
And you get a sense of the confusion around--
>>Martin: But there are things that we could
look for points of dif-, disagreement or agreement.
Here, we can say, "Democrats are" and "Republicans
are" and--
[laughter]
there's where their paths cross.
>>Josh: [ ]
>>Martin: Yeah.
[Martin and Fernanda laugh]
So, this, this is sort of an interesting thing.
I think you can start to see that by visualizing
what people are saying, you, you actually
get an interesting window into what's going
on and we wanna sort of step back for a moment
and say, "How did we get here?" And, actually,
one of the first projects that Fernanda and
I worked on was a visualization of Wikipedia,
which I'm sure I can get back for our slides
if I, let's see. Whoops, not that. Help, help
Powerpoint. Where are you?
>>Fernanda: Is it doing [ ] thing?
>>Martin: There. There we go. All right. So,
our first project together was, was visualizing
Wikipedia. And this was back in 2003 when
Wikipedia was fresh and new. No one quite
knew how it worked and we decided we would
try to figure that out the best that we could.
We looked at Wikipedia articles like this
one on chocolate--one of our favorite subjects--and
we realized anyone can edit it and when they
do they leave a trace. It's actually, it's
sort of a boon for data scientists, but Wikipedia
keeps track of everything that happens to
every page. And we realized, "Ok, this is
a lot of data to sort through. We need to
visualize it." And we came up with a method
we call "history flow" to show what's going
on. And the idea is if you've got multiple
versions of a Wikipedia page or, or really
any document, but we'll focus on Wikipedia,
you can visualize as follows. You can draw
every version as a vertical line, so that's
what you see here. And if they're multiple
authors, you can color parts of the line according
to who wrote what. So, here the lines length
tells you the length of the document and initially
Mary wrote the first part then Suzanne added
a little blue area at the end and, and so
forth. To make it easier to understand we
can connect the passages from one version
to the next that remain the same. So, here
we can see that it's very clear, for example,
between version 3 and version 4 that Suzanne
inserted a little bit of text. And we can
play other games as well where we can say,
"All right. Instead of giving every version
equal space, we'll space it according to time
between versions." That will give you a way
of really drilling down and showing the actual
texts behind each versions. The question is
what does that look like when you actually
apply that to real data?
[pause]
>>Fernanda: Ok. So, so this is history flow
and what we're looking at right now is the
evolution of the article on design on Wikipedia.
And I have this little wand here that I can
bring back in time and you can see how the
texts of the article, oh.
>>Martin: [ ] to speak to people.
>>Fernanda: Can you hear me?
>>Josh: Yes.
>>Fernanda: Ok. Oh, this is better. I can
hear myself. So, if I move my little wand
I can see how the text of the article here
changes. And I can just follow the evolution
of the article this way. So, what I can do
is look at slightly more controversial topics,
such as abortion. So, I can see that, for
instance, this is--let me bring my wand here--
this is a really, really long article that
goes on forever, but the interesting thing
here is that I have these black gashes, right,
on the visualization. And what this means
is that, at some point, the entire article
was deleted, basically. Someone just vandalized
the page and just deleted the entire article,
ok? And then eventually it gets reverted to
what it is was back. Over here someone, on
top of deleting the whole thing, said, "Abortion
is great." And then, "Abortion is good." And
then it got reverted. And what we saw by looking
at the visualization is when these things
were taking place. So, if I go back to the
first vandalism act here, I can see at the
very bottom this tells me when this happened,
so it was on the 17th of December at 4:06.
It got fixed on the same day at 4:07. So,
it took them a mon-, a minute to revert it
back. So, when we start, and, and, and we
started seeing this in many, many pages so
we, we got in touch with Wikipedians and we
were like, "How are you doing this? How are
you fixing it so fast?" So, it turns out that
Wikipedians have this thing called a "watch
list" and you can sign up to watch different
articles and then you get notified when people
make changes. And this is how they were making
the changes. They were reverting back the
vandalism. Now, let's look at our last example
here, which is one of our favorite, as Martin
said, our favorite pages, which is chocolate.
So, you immediately you get an interesting
pattern, right? I saw this and I was like,
"I need to have a scarf that looks like this
something."
[Martin laughs]
Any ideas, anyone, about what the zigzag?
About what the zigzag might be? It's a, it's
a net at war, ok? Two parties are going back
and forth about whether something belongs
on this page or not. So, someone has put something
here and then it's being, it's kept being
taken out and I can show you what that is.
So, back here this person inserted this little
piece of wide text, which is this paragraph
here that says, "Extremely rarely, melted
chocolate has been used to make a kind of
surrealist sculpture called collage." And
it survived for a while, right, until someone
said, "removing Boyer invention." That user
who had put it up was, his name is Daniel
Boyer. So, Daniel Boyer comes back and says,
"reverting chocolate collage is not a Boyer
invention." Person goes back, "Well, Google
search for chocolate collage finds only Boyer.
Reverting." "Leave your hum-bug out. Reverting."
And so forth. Until Daniel Boyer just gives
up and lets it go, which is unfortunate because
it turns out that chocolate collage does exist.
But basically, what this visualization did
is that it showed us so much data at once,
that we could very quickly get a sense of
what was sort of normal behavior on Wikipedia
and what was sort of a problem or was vandalism
because it does look different. Because you
just get a sense of what is abnormal when
you have so much data that you're looking
at.
>>Martin: So, what else can you look at when
you have a lot of data at your disposal? It
turns out there's a bunch of ways at getting
at things that, that might surprise you. I
mean, the Wiki-, Wikipedia is very Internet-based,
but you might ask, "What about, what about
the body?" And so, Fernanda and I started
a project, the Fleshmap project, to look at
how the body is treated in various ways and
one of the first things we did is we were
wondering how did people sing about the body?
How does it come up in song? And you can get
data on this. You can find lyrics all over
the Internet and before we knew it we had
a little database of ten thousand songs and
their lyrics. They were divided into eleven
genres and in a long session of brainstorming
we came up with 83 names for body parts. And
we thought, "Ok, we're gonna look genre by
genre and see how often each of these body
parts is mentioned." And it's no trouble at
all. To make a little computer script that
does this and you can quickly compile lists
like this, for example. So, in folk songs
in our sample, the word "foot" was used in
1.09 percent of our songs. Ok, not super compelling.
You can make a bar graph; it's not very compelling,
either. But what's interesting is that when
you start to graph it using imagery--and we
found a great place to get some sort of stock
photography that we could use for this-- suddenly
you start to see what's going on. So, here
you're looking at a bubble chart so each body
part is sized; the area is proportional to
how often it comes up. So, you can see that
in folk music it's sort of eye and hand and
face music with a little bit of lips and some
knees and ears. And it makes you wonder, "What
about other genres?" Well, let's take a look
at blues. It's also very simple, like a lot
of eyes, face, but you see arms, you see knees,
maybe wonder why so many knees? I dunno. People
could be down on their knees a lot in the
blues. What about other genres? What about
heavy metal, for example? Well, here you suddenly
see a greater diversity of body parts for
sure.
[laughter]
But it's still largely eye and hand and face
and it turns out that that's basically the
story across genres with one exception, which
is hip hop.
[Martin laughs]
And there we can see some of the most prominent
body parts in a single glance and also just
again, the great diversity; the body the figure's
more, more prominently here. We can actually
line these up instead of doing these one at
a time and get a kind of matrix and just see
sort of at a glance the eyes, the hands and
other parts that sort of are highly prominent.
Yes, we have a question.
>>audience member #1: Were you able to decide
if your [ ].
>>Martin: No. We, we did not do disambiguation,
so in a way, I think, this seriously under
counts certain words where there's slang that
is not, yeah. So. Yes. Yeah, we we do not
have a euphemism detector. That would be a
subject of future research though.
[laughter]
This, this is all, yes.
>>audience member #2: You actually did like
a one to one [ ].
>>Martin: Yeah.
>>audience member #2: Ok.
>>Martin: Exactly.
>>Fernanda: So, this is part of a series that
we had, that we did trying to visualize aspects
of how we relate to the body. So, another
aspect that we were interested in is how do
people think about desire when it comes to
the body? And more specifically, touching.
And how could you, you might wonder, how could
you visualize something like that? It's so
subjective, how you're even gonna get that
data? So, basically, what we did is we decided
to map hundreds of points in, on the human
body, both female bodies and, and male, male
bodies. And this is what sort of the map looks
like. And then, to gather the data, we actually
decided to turn to the Web and we used something
called The Mechanical Turk by Amazon, which
is a marketplace for very, very easy tasks
that people get paid to do. So, what we did
is we created an interface where people could
actually rate how much they wanted to touch
or be touched on different parts of the body
and we pay them money to do this. And actually,
within a couple of days we had hundreds of
people who had given us answers to that. So,
just to give you a sense of how much you get
paid, very, very simple tasks like "Are these
items different?"--these are some of the tasks
that get posted on Mechanical Turk. You might
get like a penny for that. If you are doing,
if you are identifying things on an image,
you, that's more expensive cause that takes
more cognitive power, so you get like five
cents and so forth. And so, basically, what
we did is we teamed up with Dolores Labs who
basically is a start-up that does all of the
sort of form creation to Mechanical Turk.
>>Martin: I think they're called CrowdFlower
now.
>>Fernanda: They changed. And this is what
our interface looked like. So, basically what
we would do is we would show you the person
and then we would highlight different parts
of the body of the person and you would tell
us, "Oh, that would be really great to touch."
Or, "That would, that would be a really great
place to be touched on." And then we got that
data in--
>>Martin: The scale was one apple to seven
apples.
>>Fernanda: That's right.
[laughter]
And so, oh, lemme go back and lemme show you
how that actually works. Ok. So, we decided
to visualize the data in a couple of ways.
So, this is a place where we do sort of heat
maps and this is all available on fleshmap.com.
You can go here and click on compare and these
are the results. Oh, actually, this is not
showing up. There, ok. That's better. Basically,
what we're showing here is a heat map of the
frontal male and female and obviously, the
closer to yellow the color is the more intense,
the more desirable those parts were. And you
can see that, obviously, there are results
that are very obvious here, right? We were
expecting these results, but there were some
results that might not have been so obvious.
So, for instance, if I start showing--this
is the back of the female and on the left
I have how much females desired to be touched
on these different parts of their bodies versus
on the right, how much their lovers wanted
to touch them. So you can see that you have
area of difference there. The main area that's
different is the nape; the back of the neck,
right? And it turns out that women are much
more interested in being touched there than
their lovers seemed to realize. So, keep that
in mind.
[laughter]
For some reason we were expecting a lot of
interest on the feet; not so much. And you
can start playing these games with all different
kinds of combinations. So, here's the map
for the male back and again, you see that
there is quite some difference in terms of
how the points of interest are distributed.
>>Martin: We can also visualize this in a
sort of more photographic matter. This is,
is everything showing up here? Let's scroll
a little bit. [pause] Like that.
So, we can say, "All right. Let's take a look
at this and to create a kind of cartogram,
where we've piled the body and then we can
see which places are -- sort of recede into
the distance or increase, depending on how
much they wanna touch or be touched." We also
can sort this out, so in fact, we can now
just rank order all the points of the body
according to our survey of where this woman
wants to be touched or, or people want to
touch her and in fact, women were saying the
nape was actually number one in this particular
survey. You can do the same thing with the
front of the body with men as well as women.
You can then collapse it back and put all
the pieces back together again. So, it becomes
a very interesting way to kind of get a sense
of both the body overall, but just the collective
view of the body. In some ways, I think one
of the most interesting things about this
was looking at blog comments where some people
were saying, "Oh. This is exactly what I've
expected. There's nothing new." And other
people were like, "This can't be right. Look
at the feet." And you felt like the blog commenters
themselves were telling us a lot about their
own sensations that maybe they didn't realize.
[laughter]
It was very, very interesting. So, from this
we want to segue into our current piece, which
is a fascination not with the body, but, but
with color. And let's see once I get back
to the PowerPoint here and this, the sort
of first round of our, our interest in this
particular series of colors began when we
were contacted by Wired Magazine to do a piece
for their anniversary and we were trying to
think, "Well, ok. What characterizes Wired?"
Well, among other things, the colors that
they use for the cover and we thought, "Is
there a good way that we could extract the
key colors?" We came up with a relatively
simple algorithm that basically says, "All
right. We're going to take the color cube,
divide it into little buckets and so we get
six by six by six little cubes, count the
number of pixels that fall within each bucket
and then look for buckets that are particularly
large that have a lot of pixels in them; ones
that stand out from their neighbors, there's
one called maxima and then average the values
within those buckets to kind of recover the
original colors." So, scientifically, you
can think of this geeky image up here as a
way of describing what we do, but the results
are actually kind of neat. That we can take
these covers and then get these sort of pure,
common colors that they use, arrange them
in concentric circles so that these covers
that you see would sort of be reduced to these
bulls eye patterns that characterize them.
And then you can sort of take an entire matrix
of colors, in this case they're arranged by
time. So from top to bottom are years--you
can see the first year it was just a bi-monthly
magazine. Left to right are months, so December
is at the left and, and January are, January
is at the left and December is at the right.
>>Fernanda: And--
>>Martin: Oh.
>>Fernanda: I was just gonna say these are,
this is 15 years worth of Wired Magazine covers.
>>Martin: And then when you can kind of reduce
them into this poster and you can start to
see sort of interesting patterns. I mean,
besides the fact that it's, it can be kind
of fun to look at these. They're almost like
little insects or something you're collecting.
You can immediately see from this how aha
boy in January they like to start the year
out with very clean, simple colors and they
get more complicated over time. You also get
a sense that maybe the art director changed
and they started like, liking darker colors
towards the end of their tenure. So, this
was sort of our first salvo in visualizing
color.
>>audience member #3: What [ ]?
>>Martin: That actually reflects a circulation
at the time so that this was another sort
of layer to the piece that they wanted.
>>Fernanda: So, to continue on with our fascination
with color, we got very interested in this
notion of extracting the peaks of colors from
images. Now, one of the things that happens
here on the Wired Magazine covers is that
we are aggregating so much that we are reducing
an entire cover, an entire image to a single
circle, right? To a single series of concentric
circles, which is interesting, but it's not
the only thing you could think of doing. So,
the next piece we created is called "luscious."
And there, what we were interested in is to
work within the composition of a single image,
ok. To work with the composition of a single
image and start abstracting away from the
content of the image and just looking at color.
So, basically, this is what luscious looks
like. We were interested in ads from magazines
and it was very glossy, beautiful fashion
magazines. So, this is an example where we
took an ad and created a luscious piece. And
one of the things that's interesting here
is that you start to realize how sophisticated
these color palettes are, right, from photographs.
And then you start to realize some tricks
that our eyes play on us. So, for instance,
when you look at the image on the left, you
might realize, "Ok, so this is a yellow pear
on a brownish sort of dish." Right? One of
the things that might get lost is that the
highlights on this brown dish are very, very
blue. And you can immediately see that on
the luscious, on the circles, the way the
circles, sort of the blue circles pop out
on the left there. You can also see how beautiful
the play is with darker and lighter shades
of green at the very top. So, these are all
very, very careful choices that the photographer
made and that, because we're looking at the
content, sometimes there, they get lost. So,
we decided to start doing that; pointing the
luscious algorithm to a lot of different kinds
of ads. So, this, for instance, is a Valentino
piece. And it's interesting how you get--you
definitely get--that splash of red that Valentino
is known for. It's also interesting how much
skin you see on the left versus how little
skin tone you see on the right. And then we
just keep running with it. So, this is an
Absolut Vodka ad, which tends to be very,
very heavy on the color. This is a Camel ad
and we actually like our version better than
the original. [pause] Very different color
palette, very light. Fendi, a double spread
ad by Fendi. And even Oil of Olay displaying
this really amazing palette of yellows.
>>Martin: So, once you have sort of a machine
like this for extracting colors, you wanna
run with it and our final piece, which is
showing up there, is work where we took photos
of Boston, of the Boston Common, over the
course of a year. So, we took thousands of
photos and extracted these colors taking the
time stamps into account so that we had the
characteristic colors for every month of the
year. We then arranged them on a circle. Let's
actually see if I can get that. So here are
the colors and created a kind of graph of
the waxing and waning colors of Boston. In
fact, we can go to our interactive version
here. And you can see on this graph we go
from December and we have like the cold, cold
photos of the snow and the icy sky. And then
gradually, spring comes. You can see flowers
and the colors there. Then a bulge of green
in the spring and the summer. You get a little
bit of raininess in August and then by fall
again, you can start to see the leaves, the
fall foliage. So, as we go through this we
use creative common photos, so we have the
credits here on the right, which creates a
nice element in and of themselves as I move.
This, this sort of gives a view of Massachusetts
that certainly to those of us in Boston, kind
of rings true where we feel like the time
has been revealed. So, with that I think we'll
finish up and thank you very much.
[applause]
>>Josh: Can you take a couple of questions?
>>man: They'll be here later. We, we can talk.
>>Josh: Our second speaker this evening is
Brad Paley. Brad and I met at a visualization
conference a couple years ago?
>>Brad: Something like that.
>>Josh: Yeah - when he was, he was proselytizing
one of his works; one of the four, four works
he has out in the exhibit. And I was looking
for interesting new things to think about
and we found--at least from my point of view--we
discovered that we, that, although Brad had
come into the world of data visualization
design background by now, that was my impression.
>>Brad: Ok, good. Then I've reformed because
I came into it from a coding and fine arts
background.
[Brad laughs]
>>Josh: I had come from a very, very scientific
background. We had come to a place where--
>>Brad: Yeah, that's fine.
>>Josh: where, we had very similar ideas about
how to design computer software interfaces,
but completely different arguments about why
those were the right answers, which made sitting
and having a conversation over a beer fascinating.
Since then, Brad, I guess, has roughly split
his time between designing highly usable computer
applications for, for a living and creating
really cutting edge database art, data based
art works, which have been shown in most of
the major museums in New York and around the
country and the world. As I said, there are
four of Brad's pieces out in the, out in the
lobby, which I think give an interesting cross
section of his work and he will give us a
different cross section of his work.
>>Brad: Thank you. I'm gonna start with the
four pieces out there because that's the things
you're familiar with. They're all medium old
TextArc, which should be coming up in a moment
here cause I double clicked it. These are
relatively large files. And--
[laughter]
Ah, yes. Switching computer, this is my new
lap-, tower replacement. I replaced some big
noisy energy sucker by the side of my desk.
By def it's way faster, so I suggest doing
that if you have something more than two years
old. So, this you saw out front. I'm gonna
show you an interactive version of it. I wanted
to show this first because in a very funny
way this version out front is more interactive
than the live one. And I'll point that out,
mainly, the main reason I want to do that--I'm
used to using one, I'm used to seeing one
screen so if anybody wants to move over here,
I'm gonna point at this one cause it's the
brighter of the two screens. I should've counted
people, but, but I'm too much of a projector
geek to, to follow people. I wanna follow
the brightness. The main reason that I think
this is more interactive is one of the things
that TextArc was built. It was built as a
tool for structuralist literary analysts;
people who can make some kind of hypothesis
or deduction, mostly hypothesis, from the
structure of a book, which then they can go
and read the book to find out if it's true,
but it's a different way of looking at a book.
So, if you'll notice this dormouse, hatter,
duchess, and march hare, they're all in roughly
the same place. [pause] Hello, we need a hand.
[pause] They're all in roughly the same place
in the TextArc--the lower left hand corner.
These have a very similar shape, this kind
of broken witch's broom. This has a similar
shape. This has a very different shape. I
put those things in. I call them distribution
glyphs because they show where each word is
distributed throughout the entire text. So,
I'm gonna take a step back and show you the
live version, but I wanted to point out that
the print has enough resolution that I can
actually draw the distribution glyph for every
one of them. There's no way you can do that
on a screen. And if you think about human
visual acuity, one of the things that we're
trying to play to is, is as visualization
geeks, you, you can make, you can take the
entire contents of this 1024 by 768 screen
and your eye would be able to resolve all
of that on a piece of paper about his big.
You could take any of the slides that we're
showing on the screen and see all the detail
about 18 inches away and about this big, which
means that if you're truly trying to get across
a lot of information and changes of information
aren't that big a deal, you're better off
not necessarily using, having such a paucity
of information spread out over such a big
thing, put it onto this big and if you do
have space this much then you can have roughly
what would that be? Say, 50 times 50. Who
knows what 50 squared is? You can have a hundred
thousand, a couple hundred thousand times
as much information and instant access to
it. In the case, in this case, the high resolution
allowed me to draw those and you can instantaneously
say, "Ah, these are of a family because they
seem to be mentioned in the same places."
And I'll show how a distribution glyph works
in a minute, but it was tuned so that its
shape would allow you to group things that
were used in similar, words that were used
in similar places on the book. And this one
has a very different shape. So, if I'm thinking
about these three as kind of a one, as three-
or four-headed character, I can see that instantaneously
scanning around, human brain is not very good
contrary to what we all feel at remembering
images. Very few of us have ediatic? Edietic?
How do you pronounce that word, have memory,
have that photographic memory or, or raise
your hand up? Mostly there was no evolutionary
pressure to develop a good visual memory because
the world was always there. And if you looked
away and looked back it was there again, so
there's no reason to for me to keep a whole
visual model of it there. So no selective
pressure means why waste your amino acids
and, and sugar on it. And therefore, if you
had to do something like this, an interactive
version, to see what things were--where is,
that's the code, part of the code to it—[pause]
other way. Now, the structure. Every line
of the book, "Alice in Wonderland", every
word of the book "Alice in Wonderland" scattered
around in the middle. I'll tell you how in
a minute. It's thinking about what color to
make them. There, it redrew. So, I'll tell
you what the structure is of a TextArc and
then I'll tell you about the analytic, the
visual analytic processes that people layered
on top of the structure afterwards, myself
and a few universities who are using it for
its intended purposes, and I wanna really
strongly distinguish in this early, ten year
old work the difference between the structure
of the visualization, which is a geeky color
in space trick, from the use of it in the
pursuit of humanities issues. And I wanna
suggest, I'm gonna show you some of my most
recent work just from a couple of years ago.
Ironically, for the New York Stock Exchange,
which embodies some of my most humanist work.
That's very ironic, right? But it's, it, it,
it, it, the, the, the structure and the task
and the meaning are much better integrated
in my more recent work. And so I wanna call
out the fact that the structure here is very
clearly a geeky mathematical trick. What did
I do? I took every line--like I said--and
drew it around on the outside and every word
and drew it around on the outside 'cause I
wanted to get the entire book on one page.
Second rule, there are only three rules here.
If you have to make up rules, it's good to
have few of them. Because if you have to force
somebody to learn your rules, to read your
visualization, it's nice to be able to do
it in a couple of sentences like you guys
did as opposed to have to train them for 15
minutes before they can start to understand
what the heck, how the heck you're organizing
the information. So, rule one: put all the
information up and put it in an arc. Rule
two: if a word's used a lot make it bigger;
maybe it's important. It should draw your
eye. And rule three: scatters them around,
it's kind of a spatial hashing function for
those-- who codes here? Ok [ ]. It's a useful
jargon and if, if most of you put your hands
up then, then, then, then I could get into
all kinds of questionable mappings between
how the brain works and how, how computers
work, but you've saved me from all that. You
don't have to.
[laughter]
It's pretty much bogus analogies across the
line anyway, but still.
[laughter]
We don't, we don't have cycles you don't have
bandwidth in your head. You use sugar, which
is related, but sugar takes longer to get
to places than, than bandwidth does to reallocate
itself. So, be careful with those analogies.
All right. "Alice" is used everywhere. Notice
by the way, because this is on a screen I
couldn't draw the distribution, distribution
glyphs. I just--oh, the pixels aren't small
enough. It would have been a terrible mess.
Not that it isn't now, but it's a little bit
of a structured mess. "Rabbit" is here. "Mouse"
is over here. Why is mouse over there? Well,
the rubber bands pulled it over there. "Rabbit"
is kind of here because the rubber bands pulled
it to the centrite, or tut embedding if you're
a mathematician or a force directed placement
with uniform leaning. How about that? Rubber
bands are better not just because I'm trying
to play down to you. I never play down to
an audience. I've always noticed that I've
never had to dumb anything down even for people
on Wall Street.
[laughter]
I've noticed that you can put, you can put,
here's an irony. You can put four, five, seven
times as much information on a page as people
think they can absorb. So, in other words,
when they cry, "Information overload!" and
say, "Back off," I usually go in and say,
"No, no, no, get me, let me triple that. Lemme
quadruple the information." And the more information--if
it's properly presented--actually makes it
easier to read, more comfortable to read and
that's something that is not work inherent.
I was working against how human beings evolved
and how our eyes and cognitive, cognitive
processes work here, but I'm working with
those processes in a later work. So, I'm gonna
talk just for two more minutes here because
I wanna show, I've shown you the three rules
of the structure--this averaging trick--which
scatters the words around, show all the words
in an arc and make something bigger. Here's
an example of a visual analytical technique
layered on top of that structure. You remember
"Duchess" was used in very different places
from "dormouse." Now here. Imagine you had
scan over every one of these words, right?
And remember the shapes and try to compare
those shapes in your head to see whether "hatter"
and "dormouse" and "march hare" were all mentioned
in the same place. This is just, it's a non-,
it's an impossible task. It's just not possible
no matter how good a memory you have. I would
suggest, so, depending on the nature of the
data, strangely enough, prints are better.
Hatter, dormouse and march hare all appear
here and here. They appear nowhere else. I'm
coining the term "ensemble character" because
as far as Lewis Carroll is concerned and as
far as the dramatic development of the book
is concerned, they aren't separate characters.
They're really, they're less than one-dimensional.
They're one-third dimensional because all
together they're just one-dimensional. So,
so they're really, they're really kind of
trivial characters, but they play well off
of each other. And the fact that they play,
that fact is elicited by in this representation
just by the, the shapes here. Again, "dormouse"
is something else. I used to say that "King"
and "Queen" were another ensemble character,
but somebody in a lecture once said, "No,
Brad, by your own rules they are mostly appearing
together." But they're not. Why is "Queen"
appearing out here? That's what foreshadowing
looks like to Lewis Carroll. Lewis Carroll
knew that the Queen was gonna be such an important
character here and, and less vociferous, but
no less important in the ultimate chapter.
He wanted to make her really, really have
a lot of impact when she first came on the
stage. So, in one of the few cases when I
was actually lecturing and thinking at the
same time, that person, what I did was say,
"Oh-oh. Let's, let's take a look at the text
and see what you, what those early references
are like." Here they are by the way. Just
like, they're pointing to places here. If
you've got a scroll bar, a scroll bar is a
map of your data, and if you've gotta highlight
you might as well play it out in the scroll
bar so you know where to get to them. So what
we wanna do is--and I also rigged the scroll
bar so that when I click it it just takes
me to each of these references--so, these
are the, him saying, "An invitation from the
Queen. From the Queen an invitation for the
Duchess." Invitation and Queen. First of all,
the Queen hasn't appeared. She's just being
referred to and she's, she's gonna come in
the future. Secondly, Lewis Carroll said it
and said it again. Good way to get something
into memory. Third, he's playing to what we
understand as human animals, more animals
than human. By the way, your eye evolved over
half a billion years since the Cambrian explosion.
There was an argument that, a very good argument,
that it was the eyes that drove these species
explosion around 500 billion years ago when
we only had 5 kinds of fuzzy worms underwater
and then within 30 million year we had almost
as much--maybe more--diversity as we have
right now in terms of forms. Eyes drove that
and are 500 million years old. To give you
some context, your forebrain, the symbolic
way that you read information, right, is only
four and a half million years old. I suppose
I can't even stretch that far if I make this
four and a half billion years old, right?
Million. So, -- it. Half a billion years old,
four and a half million years old for your
forebrain. Human beings have only existed
for a hundred thousand years, which is pretty
neat when you realize that civilization is
two or three thousand years old. Two or three
percent of the time that we've existed in
this form, but we had civilization in China
that long ago. And languages are able to,
symbolic; use of symbols is like 40 thousand
years old. So, it's, it's an absurd waste
of human processing. We are mostly animals.
To try to feed information to us symbolically
with words except -- when you can rely, and
you can't with all kinds of information, but
when you can rely on the, on the earlier parts
of your brain, visual processing and cognitive
recognition and categorization and things
like that you can get amazing speed ups and
benefits, which is exactly what, what we try
to do, right? We just try to push things earlier
and earlier into a visual pipeline. So, the
reason I brought it up in this context -- another
thing that human beings do very well is understand
social relationships, like alpha female. And
Queen is an alpha female, so Lewis Carroll
picked that person. He didn't say "mock turtle,"
he said, "Queen" because he wanted you to
remember arguably, this is, this is, I haven't
had a chance to talk to him about this. Hope
I never do.
[laughter]
But it's, so, so and then finally "game" if
you've read Lichtenstein, "game" is structured.
He uses that term a lot in his examples cause
it's a really hard thing to nail down, but
it's basically structured human interaction
and as animals, we're incredibly good at understanding
other animals and, and social, how we come
together and apart and things like that. So,
he did that and he basically did that for
all of those references. Here's another one,
another one and then finally, so he went one,
two--
[snaps fingers]
just when you're about to forget, three. Just
when you're about to forget, four.
[snaps fingers]
Just when you're about to forget, five, six.
And then she comes on, on the screen. Musical
structure. Beautiful, amazing word. This is
why I, and I'm sure you, do visualization
because we get to look at the geniuses of
the ages and really understand them on a different
level. Or the genius in the world as a whole
as opposed to individual people like which
is what you were just showing. So, that's
an analytical tool that was, that was discovered
after the fact because before the fact all
I was doing was trying to spread the words
out hoping that as, that my colleagues and
I could figure out ways to use this spread
out stuff. So, that's ten year ago. We'll
jump to code profiles; another piece out there,
which is about nine years old. Why are you
not zooming? Oh please. Oh, it's still, it's
a very big file and it's still reading in.
So, I'll tell you how, where it came from.
Christiane Paul, a curator of digital artwork,
saw me talk about TextArc and invited us independently
to participate in something that you put at,
on the Whitney's online site. She is a good
post-modernist on, I'm not sure if she would
like to be called a post-modern curator but
she understood those issues. She wanted to
review, she wanted to show off computer art,
but she wanted to show off how it was made.
We all know where a painting comes from cause
we did painting in, finger-painting or whatever,
in kindergarten at least. But she wanted,
she said to us, she picked ten computer artists,
"Show me, make some work for me, but also
show me the code. I want to show the world
the code so that people know what's underneath
computer art, not just the pretty face of
it." So, I was kind of at a loss because I
like, I like to deal with tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands or millions of points
and her, her aesthetic agenda to us was, "Oh
move three points in space. You're an artist;
you know what to do with that." And, in fact,
I didn't. And this is maybe why I never, I
don't really self-identify as an artist because
three points, I could never, I can't say anything
with three points. It barely makes a triangle.
You did great work with triangle by layering
other observations on top of it, Martin. But
so, so later I finally, I realized fortunately
she asked four months in advance and like
three weeks before the deadline I said, "So,
any space I want, right? Is code space? Yes,
code can be space. Ok, so I'm gonna write
a bunch of code and now I can move three points
through space because I have a whole bunch
of code. What points? Well, I'm gonna move
an approximation of your fixation point, so
how you would read it?" Following her curatorial
agenda of, of expecting people to read the
code. So, by the way, this, the aesthetic
breakthrough, the break from my writers block,
as it were, or drawer's block was when I gave
up trying to be an artist and I said, "Well,
what's her agenda? What's she trying to do?
Lemme just interpret that onto the page."
And then it all became really simple. So,
the space was code. People were gonna read
it so I traced the fixation point through--that's
the amber line. You can see this running live
outside, by the way. I finally hooked up the
projector again. The amber line just reads
simply through. The green line, which is just
kind of ghosted here, this is actually probably
ten thousand calls from a routine into here,
so that's the execution point and the white
line is my insertion point of how I, how I
wrote the code. So, this, I got beat up by
a colleague, another friend in, who is in
the same exhibition. And he said, "Well, gosh
it's really baroque. There's all these curves,"
and I'm extrapolating a little bit now, but
it is a mess. It's, and baroque is fair, it's
got a lot of curves there. And he said, "I
would have much." He said, "I would be much
more interested in this work if it was like
the minimum thing that would draw itself on
a screen." Which is a neat trick if you go
to MIT and you're focused on that kind of
elegant computer problem, but I was focused
on human communication. And the baroqueness,
this stuff, notice that these lines are perfectly
straight. That's the following of the execution
point around here. There's no reason to think
there's any flow. The computer just kinda
jumps from one place to another. When I was
writing the code, though, I was in a flow
state. What Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi calls
a flow state; it's, he's a person who studies
optimal human performance, intellectual and
even emotional states while you're doing your
absolute best. And I was in a flow state when
I, I was just rippin'. Every bit of information
was just right there at my fingertips. Wait
a second. I wish I could do this in my life
more than two percent of the time, but--
[Brad laughs]
so, so I was, though, at this point. Thank
you, Christiane, for inviting me to do this.
And so it was completely, absolutely inappropriate
and wrong to draw that as a straight line.
It should flow. In fact, I used a natural
cubic because that had an even more flowing
feel to it than a B-Spline would. I mean,
there are various ways you can draw curves
on a computer. So, this is, this is a bit
of a direction away from just the raw presentation
of data on the screen, trying to interpret
it in a way that's more associated with how
people are gonna read it; what task they're
gonna use it for. So, now I'll do very quick
discussions of these two. This is my most
successful failure. I, now I don't care. I
say it's successful because it was published
in Science and Geo and Discover and I can't
remember, many, many magazines and I still,
to this day, even though it's many years old
get requests for people to use it in their
thesis on their wall in the science department
or something. Every spot is a different area
of science, the lines are kind of like those
rubber bands from TextArc, say, we told every
spot to push away from all the other spots.
However, we held the bits, the areas of science
that were related to each other together with
similar rubber bands to the ones that I used
in TextArc and that's what created this shape.
So, all the organic chemistry stuff was over
here and it's kind of related to physical
chemistry, which is kind of related to applied
science and physics and astrophysics; so these
things are all related to each other. I invite
you to look at that if you want. I added this
because this is actually just kind of a curiosity,
not really a tool and I pride myself on being
a toolmaker of late--try to anyway. And so,
this does become a tool though when you take
that map and say, "Oh, well the United States
is heavy in medicine and social sciences and
doesn't do much of the mathematical stuff.
Canada and, Canada and United Kingdom are
pretty similar. Australia's similar. France
and Germany and Spain are very well rounded."
See how their spots are pretty evenly distributed
around the whole space. China and Taiwan are
pretty much very complementary to us so if
you're doing a startup, you might want to,
and you need tech and humanities and medicine,
you may want to involve people on a couple
of different continents, this is what it's
saying. So, this, I was calling it a failure
because the very thing I think that made people
really wanna, really want to use it in these
various settings is completely an artifact
of a bad algorithm that I designed to lay
out the text. So, this, all of those, those
hairs, was called the Flying Spaghetti Monster
or, or--
[laughter]
I can't remember what other things I thought
it was a feather ball, it's a, I was just
trying to instead of just put, putting spots
on the screen, or spots rather on the print--no
way you could do this on a screen--spots on
the print, I wanted to label each one with
the words that were most commonly used in
that area because then it becomes fun to read
through the whole thing and see how the concepts
are related to one another. The reason I call
it a failure is because, because it looks
hairy. Because you're, it's drawing much more
attention to itself and there's no information
driving this shape. I mean, if they all were
slightly curved like this, then it would elicit
the kind of humanist understanding of science,
not as a dry, technical discipline, but as
a, as a humanist discipline as aspiring to
understanding the human or the physical condition
as novel writing or painting is. But science
is like that. We outside of science don't
necessarily know that, so I was trying to
give it a little bit more of a human face
and I think that would be enough, but this,
all this nasty stuff is just grrrr! It's drawing
your eye and it's drawing your eye to faults
in my algorithm. Seriously.
[laughter]
I would mark somebody 'C' on that. Fortunately
I didn't have anybody I was deploying to that
was quite so mean about this. Now, the last
thing in the show, so you see, I hope you're
seeing there's kind of an arc here where I'm
trying to make tools that are more understandable
by human beings because of things they already
know, or because of things they're already
prewired for. This is the last thing out there.
It's a calendar. I think I'm proudest of this.
I'm certainly proudest of this of any of the
things out there even though it's sparse it's
very regular because the data I was showing
is very regular. It's hours in the day. It's
not you. There. [pause] Hours in the day and
it's a pretty much, it's pretty similar from
day to day. I mean, there are, there are a
couple of days that are a little bit funny
like, like this one. 12, 1, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6 and that's daylight savings time. You roll
back in fall. There's a double line just because
that's the beginning. It so happened that
the, that Friday both started and ended this
year, or started and will end this year. Ok,
so this thing though I'm proudest of because,
I'll go, if you're interested later I can
talk about the agenda. It has an insidious
existential agenda. I'm a child of the 70s
before semiotics and, and we were interested
in existentialism and the point of this was
if you mark something on here and then do
your email for a minute and you look up and
you say, "Oh, I marked that, but it's already
two hours have elapsed." I'm tying a recognizable
flow rate of your minute to minute, or at
least hour to hour experience to the entire
year and I was trying to scare us all, letting
us realize we almost never, there's very little,
there's, it's very hard to tie big numbers
and small numbers together. Remember my half
billion years of eye evolution? And forty
thousand or twenty thousand years of linguistic
evolution? It's really hard to think of those
in the same mental breath and this was me
trying to span a couple of orders of magnitude.
I actually did an even scarier one that turned
out to just be design gesture. It wasn't very
useful. This thing could be useful if you
mark things on it. Actually, we have somebody
who's used it more virtuostically than anybody
in the world and he's in the audience here,
too. You've sent me pictures of using this
to really plot out things and the idea is
you, you might see some patterns in your life.
This is about, about, this is graph paper
on which to plot your life, basically. But
the scarier one that I did, I was almost gonna
do for 2010. It wasn't gonna be useful as
a tool, but I could collapse all these together
and spiral in and it would have had to have
been a little bit bigger, but I could've put
an entire decade on a page and still show
you hour to hour changes. And I really liked
the idea that for the rest of my life I've
got like two productive pages, maybe three.
[laughter]
And once I turn those pages I'm into senility
and I might have another extra page and a
half. And I like to threaten myself, and I
suggest that it's a valuable thing to do if
you want to, and get up out of bed some morning
when you don't have to and get something accomplished.
This thing, the main reason I'm proud of it,
though, was not necessarily that agenda, some
of which I admit was formed after I made it
and looked at it and thought about what it
would be used for, I don't have to explain
this to anybody. I just hand it to them. They
figure it out themselves. Why? Because red
for weekends and out here is a standard type
of graphic structure, ok, is a standard typographic
way of showing, of showing things. Certainly,
the features of January, February, ziiiiiiip!
December are things that people recognize.
They eventually recognize that, "Oh, this
is hump day." The low part of the week and
this is the high part of the week, the weekend,
at least at the top part of the, that's so
the little, the frills are on the outside
are showing weeks. There are something, somewhere
between nine and twelve "aha" reactions that
I've intentionally engineered into this because
when I give it to you; I wanna make you feel
smart. I wanna give ya that ex-, that ability
to look at it and figure stuff out yourself
because we all love that, right? And the only
reason that that's possible is because you're
so smart to begin with and I'm just giving
you something that has features that if you
trust me enough, as a visualization person,
you will look at and say, "Brad must have
done this for a reason. He's not somebody
who reads in random numbers and vomits colors
onto the screens because they give you two
seconds worth of visual retinal titillation.
He's not one of those guys." There are many
of those guys. Mostly guys. "When he puts
a Martin on the page it means something."
And so then, then you have an excuse to look
into it more deeply and those excuses all
come around, the intention of an author trying
to get meaning across and leaving a breadcrumb
trail of breadcrumbs--recognizable features--that
you'll be able to tap into. So, now I wanna
show something that I didn't do and then I'll
give you just quick, quick glances of more
recent work. So, I was going from ten to eight
to six to four years old. This is not my work.
God, I wish it were. It is about 150 or 170
years old. It does, I wanna suggest far better
information visualization than I may ever
get to and that I think almost anybody in
the world is able to do it. It's a page from
the 19, or sorry, 1810 Encyclopedia Britannica.
And why do I call it, why am I so enthralled
with this? It's just an engraving, right?
Here's why: Trying to get across a message.
You wanna give people "aha" reactions; you
wanna tap into things that they already recognize.
You wanna give them features to allow them
to understand and discover it. I don't have
to tell you for a second, I don't have to
say things, but I will just to show you this
approach to understanding a work like this.
No, thank you. What a shot. Go away. Oh. Thank
you. Ok, elevation, plan. You knew that. Why?
Because the elevation is drawn like mountains
and the plan is drawn relatively flat. This
is swampland, this is farmland and this is
a structure. I didn't have to tell you any
of that. You--
[snaps fingers]
Instantaneously, preattentively, before the
third of a second that it takes for a stimulus
to get to your forebrain, this thing was already
parsed. It was already recognized to you before
you even saw it in a sense. There are really
cool magical tricks you can play with your
mind when you realize that people live a third
of a second in the past. There are ways to
get information into their heads in a tenth
of a second or two-tenths of a second, so
that it's already there when they come aware
of it and that's the essence of making a good
tool. And that's what this person did. This
is a, this is a phenomenal tool and just one
other thing. This top, so, the features that
I was talking about that are breadcrumbs that
allow you to instantaneously recognize things
and distinguish things, I wanna suggest that
when you draw something, every distinct intellectual
category should have a distinct visual vocabulary
that you draw it with because there is instantaneously
distinguishable as this and this and you people
here. We are built, we are evolved to make
instantaneous preattentive distinctions between
things that look different and so I can look
at the people and ignore the chairs or look
at chairs and ignore the people. He allowed
us to do that and then, even more virtuously,
he tied the plan and the elevation together
with this dotted line overlay. Dotted lines
indicate virtual or intellectual things and
it's just, it's just gorgeous stuff. I wanna
zoom into this--I know I'm over the five minutes,
but I just, I am excited to share this with
you. So, I just wanna show the amazing detail
in this and the beautiful resonances, visual
poetry that, the waves aren't really that
big. But we know it's water because he's referring
to waves, right? It's not a slavish translation
of the real world. It's not a photograph;
it's a reinterpretation that allows us to
parse it and understand it as information
much more easily. The punch line for this,
by the way, is that that's the real size.
[Brad laughs]
It's this big. And anybody who wants one I
printed up a bunch. I'd be happy to send you.
Finally, in the negative four minutes I have
left I'll--
[laughter]
show you. Leave if you want to. I really apologize.
But there are ways that you can turn this
into more quotidian things. This is work that
I did for the New York Stock Exchange. And
I'm trying to learn how to distinguish things
that are really important to look at, things
that are temporary post-it like overlays on
information, things that are paper like because
they're forms with the square corners versus
screen like because there are round corners,
things that are basic information and interpretations
of the information and this is how you can
start to put in two, three, four, seven times
as much information that people are asking
for. And the information, if it's related,
and if you visually layer it properly and
draw it so that it's instantaneously recognizable
in this preattentive way, so it's recognized
before you see it, in a sense, before you're
conscious of it, it becomes paradoxically
more comfortable. Why? Because it's feeding
our visual and cognitive processes in the
way that, in the way that the real world does.
And all of a sudden, it becomes as effortless
as looking around in a room like this. Reduce
this room to a spreadsheet, right? It's gonna
be a 150 thousand line spreadsheet if we ignore
most of the interesting stuff and that's gonna
be a useless spreadsheet. The only reason
you can look around this room and do this--I'm
hoping that I'm doing for some of my clients
and I promise I'll come back to, after, after
I retire from Wall Street. I mean, why am
I doing this on Wall Street? Because they
happen to be able to make money out of this
stuff and they're, they're willing to fund
it. But I'm gonna bring this stuff back into
probably nanotechnology or some, some positive
technical humanist thing. Different layers
from different kinds of information and you
can see I'm nowhere near as virtuosic as that
anonymous person from 150 years ago. We all
have a lot to learn. I invite you guys to
join me and surpass me on this stuff. Thanks
for listening.
[applause]
>>Josh: That was, that was an hour and a half
[ ].
>>Brad: Ok.
[Brad and Fernanda laugh]
>>Josh: Are there any questions? Please don't
wait on me.
>>audience member #4: That needs some discussion.
I [ ]
>>Brad: Great stuff.
>>audience member #4: [ ]
>>Brad: Yeah. Yeah, so the question was that
there's been discussion about Apple using
very physical or physics based bits of the
interface. Like, for instance, on the OFM
when you scroll past the end of a list it
lets you and then it generally pops you back.
All sorts of things like that. And the debate
evidently is should we hearken back to this
plain old physics fake stuff or should we
be inventing new paradigms? And my somewhat
glib, but mostly heartfelt answer is absolutely.
Invent completely new paradigms for demonstrating
data as soon as our wiring has changed. That's
gonna be another 500 million years, so I think
that those people who are on that side of
the argument, actually it may not be 500 million
years. There are gimmen-, there are gimments
if you survive the next hundred years, and
most of you under twenty probably will, are
most of you under thirty probably will, then
you'll be uploaded and then it might be much
quicker to change some of the hardwiring that
I have to take for granted cause I'm 52 and
I'm gonna die in 50 years--
>>audience member #5: [ ]
>>Brad: But--
>>Brad: Well, it's, I mean, you can, you can
turn it into the behavioral version of chart
chunk, right? You can, where, "Oh is it really
enhancing my ability to deal with this? To
turn the page." I think it's a, I said I was
being somewhat glib, but mostly heartfelt.
If you're, to really address that there is
a simple, simple thing that you wanna do.
You wanna say, "Given the hardware of human
perception and the software, as it were, of--"
I just lapsed into those nasty analogies anyway,
didn't I? Excuse me. "And the software of
human cognition and categorization and things
like this." Given that, set that aside, that's
what we're feeding, understand what the task
is, if you can, if you can be true to the
task and tie into some physics stuff like
that scrolling past the end of the list, is
beautiful because it lets my gut know that
I'm scrolled past the end of the list and
I'm tapping into the hardware and the learning
that I've done about physics in the real world.
If you can align all of those interests then
absolutely do it because what it does is it
offloads that information from your forebrain
to your body. And the key thing about that
is it lets your foregrain-, forebrain go on
and do what it was supposed to do. I do not
go to my phone to use a scrollbar to find
the end of the list. I go to my phone to find
a human being and if my fingers can take care
of going through the list, then my mind can
think about that human being and it's freed
up to think about other human beings. So,
yeah.
>>Josh: So you really want your users to feel
something then it should look like a lion
or [ ].
[laughter]
>>Brad: Absolutely. One of the, one of the
problems with, one of the problems with the
thing I just showed you, remember there was
an alert that was bright red in the, in the
middle of the screen? One of the problems
with that is I'm misaligning interests in
a way that I'm trying to avoid. That thing
was the brightest, prettiest thing on the
screen. And it's the most dangerous damn thing
that could happen to a specialist on the floor
of the New York Stock Exchange. So, they know
after a while, "Oh yeah, I better be aware
of that." But there's some part of them saying,
"Ooh, pretty. I want more of that."
[laughter]
And they really don't. So, so, I misaligned
these myself. Yeah. I pointed at this gentleman
first. Probably cause his hand went up first.
>>audience member #5: [ ] Let's say you have
no gravity. The speed of a bouncing ball [ ]
>>Brad: Yeah, yeah. We would learn that other
thing.
>>audience member #6: [ ]
>>Brad: I didn't have, in 35 minutes, enough
time to do all of the proper academic escapes
and cautions in that. I think of it as hardwired
because, because as far as I'--
>>audience member#6: [ ]
>>Brad: Right.
>>audience member #6: [ ].
>>Brad: We, we are amazingly flexible within
certain limitations and it's, that's a question
to talk to psycholinguists and cogno scientists
about. Point taken. I take it as a designer,
not a cognitive scientist, as a designer I
take it as given because most of us grow up
in a pretty similar world. However, your point
does bring up the point that, that we grew
up in a similar world with respect to physics,
but not with respect to culture. And so, if
you wanna use red as "hot" in physics and
you think that that means a high number and
you go to Wall Street and you proudly show
them a visualization--I did this 20 years
ago where I used a heat map and they said,
"Lemme get this straight. Black is low and
when I'm in the red that's good? Oh, ok, fine."
Different cultures have different color mappings
and we need to be aware of that. It's part
of our ability to learn.
>>audience member #6: [ ].
>>Brad: Yeah, which will work unless you're
in China where it's up and down or Jewish
where it's backwards.
>>audience member #6: [ ].
>>Brad: Yeah.
>>Josh: The back button. [ ] down.
>>audience member #6: [ ].
>>Brad: Yeah, exactly. Yeah. You need to take
advantage of your culture.
>>audience member #7: It's really very interesting
to hear you talk about [ ] feeding the brain
in a way that will reward us and these ideas
of the breadcrumbs and visual cues that you
recognize before your conscious does--
>>Brad: Mm-hmm. Exciting stuff.
>>audience member #7: I'm wondering if you
have any ideas about the third dimension in
data visualization and spatial memory? There's
something called the HNR memory where--
>>Brad: Where you visualize a room, a structure
and you put ideas in the structure?
>>audience member #7: Right. And you use physical
notations to bookmark some ideas and [ ]. Do
you see that as our [ ] limitation to talk
about creative--
>>Brad: Yeah. Well, think about what that
is, by the way. You're using your amaz-, your
eye and what your eye has created, which is
this remarkable ability to deal with space
and remember spatial structures, and you're
using that to leverage something that we really
weren't built for at all, which is memorizing
lists of things. So you walk through the space
and you leave this idea here, this idea there,
this idea here and then when you walk through
the space again you, if the things are tied
with the space. Yeah, so, they're doing, that
was high-tech, very high-tech when the Greeks,
I guess it was, did that stuff. I'm not sure
I'd call that the third dimension. That's
still, I mean, it, I mean, I think of three
dimension as three dimensional visualization
stuff and that's, it's a hard thing to pull
off well and I'm interested to see somebody
do it and I'm not sure I have seen anybody
do it yet. We can talk later if you want to
talk.
>>audience member #7: [ ]
>>Brad: Yeah because it's volumes worth of
stuff and I've only read half of one of the
volumes, but at least we could have the beginning
of that talk.
>>audience member #8: My question is actually
very related to that. This excitement in mathematics
where there's [ ].
>>Brad: Ok.
>>audience member #8: Which basically says
higher dimensional space does not act like
two dimensional spaces.
>>Brad: Oh. Ok, fine.
>>audience member #8: So, for example, there's
something called the exotic seventh sphere
where you start with an eight dimensional
cube and sort of sand off its edges so that
you can shrink it down to a sphere.
>>Brad: Ok.
>>audience member #8: Which is what would
happen in three dimensions and two dimensions--
>>Brad: Mm-hmm.
>>audience member #8: Well, in eight dimensions
there's thirty eight different kinds of spheres
and they're all spheres. They all have constant
[ ] but they're not shaped the same.
>>Brad: Interesting.
>>audience member #8: It's such a strange
idea we can't even--
>>Brad: Yeah. Well, there are three kinds
of parallel lines you can do even in our universe,
right?
>>audience member #8: Exactly. And that was
the start obviously that something's not maybe
as simple as, it seems like this is a big
dilemma for you guys who are in higher dimensional
spaces [ ] not making that things like the
notion of the nearest neighbor is not as simple
as it might be if I project down.
>>Brad: I see.
>>audience member #8: or if I take my touch
points and count them up and put them on a
dimensional grid with their nearest neighbors
[ ]. But if you're in a higher dimensional
space you don't take into account the age
of the people, the sexuality. It's the same
problem [ ] Pandora. It's a lot of complaints
like, "How come when I'm listening to my rock
and roll all of a sudden I hear it's not."
[Brad laughs]
And he's got 60 parameters that can measure
[ ].
>>Brad: Yeah.
>>audience member #8: He's in 60 dimensional
space. How does that work?
>>Brad: Yeah, but you know if I gave you a
list of stocks and their prices today, yesterday
and two days ago, you wouldn't necessarily
call that a three dimensional space. There's
no continuity, there's no sense of whether
it's bounded or not, I mean, we use dimensions
in kind of a wonky way. I mean, when somebody
talks about a 60 dimensional space it has
nothing to do with the eleven dimensions in
which we live and the three of which we are
aware. So, when you conflate those two things
it sounds like we have a harder problem than
when you disentangle them. The multi-dimensional
space issues are well taken care of by, and
you guys know this better than I do, these
guys know the math behind the, a lot of these
things like multi-dimensional scaling or finding
Eiken vectors through higher quote dimensional
spaces. But those, that, the arbitrary scaling
of those different quote "dimensions" is well
taken care of by certain kinds of mathematical
tricks. And the thing that I wanted to disentangle
is the space we live in and train our brains
to be able to respond to is very strictly
three, it's really only three dimensions;
it's even silly, in a sense, to call time
the fourth dimension. That's just freshmore's
trying to sound clever. It's something that
has no physical reality that we can tie into
with it. You couldn't just swap width for
time. It doesn't work that way.
>>audience member 8: It's a clear game.
>>Brad: Yeah. Someone suggested, I want to
suggest that you're right -- we could've been
in danger there, but fortunately it's just
a linguistic confusion that's tying together
dimensions of one sort with dimensions of
another.
>>audience member #8: [ ] those things that
are the predecessor. the pre-announcement--
>>Brad: Yeah, foreshadowing.
>>audience member #8: By your own admission,
when you look at the texts, you say, "Oh.
Wait a minute. This is a third person reference.
It's not that [ ] that Queen spelled Q-U-E-E-N
is in a different [ ].
>>Brad: It's a different concept. Yeah.
>>audience member #8: Right. But on your thing
You heat wave, you heat wave. And you even
let the young person who's trying to write
their Alice in Wonderland that all they have
to do is indruce the queen buh-buh-buh and
that person – they don't get the rest of
your lecture. They don't hear the part "Oh,
by the way. You might want to put the notion
of the queen in somebody else's minds."
>>Brad: That's a good, that's a good point.
So, I should be careful if I give somebody
a map and say, "Here's where the ice cream
store is." I should be careful that they don't
try to cut it out and eat it. I'll be very
careful about that in the future.
[Brad laughs]
That there are people who I could confuse
because this is a new kind of map, into thinking
this was reality, but at our best we're showing
one fractured view of an incredibly rich phenomenon
than I think we all realize that. That's my
inspiration for going on actually, because
I wanna unfracture it and show two views before
I die. Do we--
>>lady: Yeah, we have time for another question.
>>Brad: Ok, yes.
>>audience member #9: [ ].
>>Brad: Yeah.
>>audience member #9: [ ] feeling of elegance
– kind of [ ].
>>Brad: It's so beautiful.
>>audience member #9: [ ].
>>Brad: Oh that's true. So, just the very
interpretation is focusing your eye on it.
Maybe that's where the art comes in. That's
what artists are supposed to do.
>>audience member #9: [ ].
>>Brad: It's not poss-, it's not impossible
to do that. You can, Victor Vescarelli, for
instance, a pop artist of far too high stature
compared to his talent, as far as I'm concerned.
Is he still alive? Is this going out on the
air? Ok. That's good, I think. But, was able
to draw things that were much more realistic
looking than real, than they could by--actually,
Salvador Dali, whose early work I respect
very, very highly, intentionally did something
that your retina does. It takes a light, low,
a high level of light and a low level of light
and your retina has cells that span the receptors
under the low light and the high light and
the cells--retinal ganglion cells-- that span
those two say, "Ooh. This is bright and this
is dim. I'm gonna make this one even dimmer
and this one even brighter so the apparent
profile at an edge is like this." And Salvador
Dali said, "Well, I'm trying to make things
that are illustrations of things in dreams,
which are hyper-, more real than real by definition
because dreams are just meant to, some people
would say, work through an emotion and you
invent objects to help you work through the
emotion and the objects have to be more real
than external reality because they are built
from the forms of internal reality-- the perfect
Platonic ideal, right? So that they are truly
more real than this stuff.
[knocks on wood]
So Salvador Dali was trying to illustrate
that and so he took this, which your retina
does, and did it even more and that's one
of the visual tricks that he may or may not
have even known he was, I mean he knew what
he was doing, he implied in every one of his
brushstrokes. I don't know if you knew where
it came from, retinal ganglion cells, but
it's certainly possible to feed the machinery
that we have to engage with it even better
than reality and it's a really, really hard
thing to do though. But it's, I wouldn't expect
us, I wouldn't expect us to--
>>audience member #9: [ ].
>>Brad: I'm sorry?
>>Brad: Well, you know what? It just leaves
me in awe of evolution and how it could have
put together something so facile, so instantaneously
workable. Of course, instantaneous on our
time frame and we evolved with the time frame
so [ ]. Take out instantaneous there, but
it leaves me in awe of the fact that we have
this machinery that can take in so much information
and parse it out at so many different levels,
edges and textures and people and behavior
and meaning and social context and future.
It's so it doesn't, it's not like hmmm? And
it's not like, confusing, it's just – it's
awesome in the pre-1980s use of the word.
[laughter]
>>Josh: And let's bring it to an end there.
Thank you very much, everybody.
[applause]
Thank you Brad.
Thank you Martin and Fernanda.